emmanuel macron est attendu ce matin aux
mureaux dans les yvelines le président
de la république profitera de son
déplacement pour aborder le sujet du
séparatisme
mais aussi dévoilé les grandes lignes de
son projet de loi visant principalement
à lutter contre l'islam politique et
l'islam radical
le débat sur le séparatisme est prévu au
parlement pour le premier semestre 2010
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec françois pupponi si ancien maire de
sarcelles et député du val d'oise
françois pupponi bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france alors tout d'abord quels sont
les enjeux de cette visite des manuels
m'apprend aux mureaux les gens je sais
que la république est astuces sur le
public elles réagissent enfin vis-à-vis
de phénomènes qui sont en train de saper
les bases de notre institution
républicaine à la fois bien sûr l'islam
politique savent radicale mais d'autres
vont t'ils séparatistes aussi et dont il
était temps enfin que la france non
seulement en pleine conscience mais ils
légifèrent dise les choses et que le
créant la république que 10 des mots je
pense que c'était important pour notre
pays
qu'attendez vous du discours des manuels
m'apprend sur le séparatisme déjà qu'on
vous dise un peu quelle est la ligne de
conduite ce que pensent les tas de ce
sujet quelles seront les grandes lignes
du projet de loi que nous aurons à
débattre en début d'année prochaine
parce que ça sera moins important à la
fois pour notre pays un moment important
que j'en suis sûr aussi pour la fin de
ce quinquennat parce que ce sujet du
séparatisme de ceux qui veulent saper la
pluie sera sujet à eux fondamentales
pendant la campagne électorale
donc il est important que l'europe et
donc la voie dit ce qu'il pense et
ensuite que nous puissions débattre
justement quelles doivent être les
grands axes de ce plan sont en vo c'est
que ceux qui ne reconnaissent pas les
lois de la république
ceux qui ont envie d'imposer leurs
propres lois aux autres eh bien on
puisse leur dire voilà le cadre voilà ce
qui est autorisé voilà ce qui ne l'est
pas et ça aujourd'hui le droit français
de l'europe ne dit pas c'est la loi est
trop flou et la poule la république n'a
jamais vendre pris position parce que je
pense qu'il voulait peut-être et la
réalité donc au moins l'idée c'est de
poser un cadre et que les gens soient
mobilisés que les institutions
républicaines soient mobilisés contre ce
qu'est en train de nous saper les
fondations mêmes de notre institution
merci beaucoup françois
pouponner d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien maire de sarcelles et député du
val d'oise